with infinity war now on general release
throughout the world many fans have been
poring over it frame by frame in order
to pick out the most minor details if
you would door fan theories like me and
you know that they can dramatically
change the way that you watch a film
this one by redditor s j bkr gr one
definitely changes my thoughts on the
post-credits scene of infinity war and
sheds new light on the previous MCU
films the redditor states that we should
not be asking why fury never called on
Captain Marvel before infinity war
instead we should change our perspective
and ask why did Nick Fury call on her
this time what is offered up by the
writer is an incredible thought on
Fury's place throughout the entire MCU
line of films and they state that one
during the post credits scenes fury
appears confident when Maria
disintegrates like he knows what's going
on - he immediately goes for the pager
like he was prepared for the event 3 in
age of Ultron when he meets with Tony
Fury says that he's not the director of
anybody just an old man who cares about
Tony very much this is an odd turn of
phrase as prior to this they hadn't
really had much of a relationship and
periods normally really stand offish
with most people before later in the
same conversation Tony tells fury of the
vision scholar which gave him where he
kills the Avengers and the whole world -
fury looks intrigued at the idea that
Tony could have seen such a thing
and he then tries to come for him by
saying it was a trick but Tony insists
that he was shown in stark says watching
my friends die you'd think that'd be as
bad as it gets
nope wasn't the worst part which fury
interrupts with the worst part is that
he didn't the reddit estates that all of
the above points hint towards the fact
that Fury had prior knowledge to the
events of infinity war emphasizing that
they think the Captain Marvel film will
show us that fury has either a scene
or being told the future where a man
named Ironman will save the universe or
be has seen the snap inning before to
some degree they also theorized that
when stark announced himself to be
Ironman that it was Fury's cue to
introduce stark into the world of
superheroes because he knew he would be
of the utmost importance one day this
would explain why he immediately wanted
to recruit stop and train him to be a
competent soldier it would also explain
why he's tried time and time again to
save star from himself it would also
emphasize the fact that when stark
explained his visions of killing the
Avengers and the world that it wasn't
the worst part fury knows that stark was
still alive and perhaps Fury already
knew this prophecy finally it would also
answer the question as to why Fury
didn't call on Captain Marvel until
infinity war perhaps in the past he was
shown or learned that in the future
there would be some catastrophic event
where she would be needed and that's why
when Maria disappeared he quickly went
to get the pager they don't think it was
out of fear but instead was out
recognizing what the situation was
personally I think that this is an
incredible theory that not only clears
up by fear II was so quick to grab the
pager but also explains how the spy
manages to stay one step ahead of
everyone else
time and time again I can't wait to see
if Captain Marvel highlights more of
this or if it will be brushed aside as
another one of Marvel's best fan
theories what do you think is there
legitimacy to it or do you disagree
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film recently I
discuss my fan theory on how Odin was
the original Danis so make sure you
check out that video next linked at the
end of this one thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you
[Music]